this was asked by someone who I think
was getting married:
what would be the most interesting metal to make a ring from?
I suppose if you were getting married... one of the most interesting metals would be a magnetic alloy
an interesting metal for a ring...
you probably couldn't use iron, because
that might rust
well, platinum and gold are often used... so is copper, so
it can't be any of those. I think it would
have to be...
diamonds are a girl's best friend, just shove some diamonds in there.
you know what I would like? I would like
to have some kind of--
I know, like a... a ring that encases mercury.
I suppose quite a novel ring would be
made of mercury
so it's like something like a strong
glass or something like that you know
but obviously it's got to be delicate
to fit on your finger but say that the
mercury will just constantly slosh
around
we really have to cool it down to keep
it on your finger
that would make the most interesting
thing and also the you know it is quite
risky wearing it, isnt it? 'Cause any time if it breaks so you just could
cover yourself in mercury--maybe not the best idea.
I don't know
interesting metal...
interesting...
goodness... i dunno, titanium is pretty light, very stiff
what about a cesium ring? [laughs]
platinum would be quite nice... but gold is
also nice, i mean--
interesting? no, i don't know maybe they're just standard. what be most interesting...
so the melting point of gallium is quite
close to the body temperature, isn't it, so
if you could make a ring out of gallium
whatever your normal body temperature
that the ring would probably sit quite
nicely on your finger, because it's
cooled by the environment, but if you
would get like, hot and perhaps feverish,
and the ring would probably start to melt, so that would be quite interesting
[laughs]
I don't know!
yeah, I don't know.
I'd like to see just how heavy a lead
ring would be
imagine if a couple had magnetic rings,
then when they [claps] held hands, they'd stick together
oh, I think bismuth would be good, cus I remember the bismuth videos, and it looks very pretty.
[laughs]
I don't know
wedding rings a really special, aren't they?
you know, it's what matters to you and
it's the metal that you associate with
the person you want to be with.
carbon fiber-- that's not metal is it though? titanium.
I don't know... be expensive. I think, just go with gold. it's-- it's pretty good
Mark, my ring--my wedding ring is made out of-- it's made out of Welsh gold
so, obviously because of the Welsh
connection, so my wife and I have got a
matching Welsh gold wedding ring, so.
BRADY: Well, how is Welsh gold different to other gold?
well, Welsh gold's no different to gold
that's made anywhere else, you know
perhaps Ethiopia or mined in South
Africa, but i suppose what makes it Welsh gold
is where it was mined, and it was mined
in a-- in a small valley in north
wales so it's quite close to my home and
quite close to my family links